Okay.
What? Bring water. Bring water right
now.
Yeah.
What happened to your
group here? reach out to me as with you
and the other person. Reach out to me
separately and we'll talk about what to
do. Okay. Email's fine. Yeah. Don't
worry about it. We'll figure something
out.
Put it face up. Okay. There any more
quizzes out there? Please bring them in.
Time is up. Time is up.
That should be good.
Okay.
Oh, there.
Okay. So, while we wait for people to
come in from the other
class, same rules as the previous
quizzes, right? I'll let you know when
the quizzes are ready. Hey, folks, if
you want to talk about the quiz, please
re leave the room.
went all
over. So there are a couple of things I
want to do
today. Folks, you want to talk about the
quiz, you can leave the room or you can
stay in the room and listen. Okay.
The room must sit down. We can make a
choice. You can either sit in and listen
or talk about the quiz
outside. So, I will let you know when
the quizzes are
done. I'm not even going to open up
packet two because there are a few more
pages there.
Hey folks in the back, either leave the
room or stay in the room and listen to
the class. Okay, make your choice.
I don't need to clap.
Okay.
Oh, the gentleman in the white. Can you
get the gentleman in the white
sweatshirt back there behind you? Can
you get that gentleman behind you? Just
pat him. Pat him. Say, ask him to look
forward. We're in class. Okay. You only
can have a discussion. Please leave the
room. Okay. So there are rather than
open up packet two, I'm going to kind of
close up that IPO discussion by kind of
framing four separate issues that kind
of bring together I think the issues
with IPOs. So last session we talked
about what you do in an IPO. You price
the company. The banker gives a
guarantee of the price. And because a
banker gives a guarantee of the price,
they tend to underpric things which
makes sense. In fact, on average, an IPO
is underpriced by about
15%. How do we know that so precisely?
How would you measure how much an IPO is
underpriced by
Sophia? On the first day of trading, you
look at the open of trading because a
banker sets a price on the when it
opens, if it's underpriced, the price
jumps on average about 15%. You ready
for the first question? And I think we
kind of answered this last session. Why
can't we make money by buying every IPO
then on average you should make that 15%
jump right what do you think why why is
it so difficult to make money be very
volatile basically I can live with a
volatility with an average jump of 15%
in a day I mean I have a lot of
yes that's even better right you make
the money here it's not a we're not
playing an intrinsic value game we're
playing a trading game you buy every IPO
what are you going to do Hold it through
the first day. Sell it at the end of the
first day and collect your 15%
jump.
Yes. Okay. Here's the first thing. You
ask for a,000 shares in every IPO. Let's
I could give you the list. In fact, I'll
give you a website today which lists out
every IPO that's coming for the next 6
months. So, you put in a request for a
thousand shares in every single IPO.
Will you get a thousand shares in all of
them? How would the bank? So let's say
the bankers don't play, you know,
favorites, which they sometimes do.
Let's say it's unbiased. How do they
decide how many?
It's not even about you, right? So what
does the banker see? He sees the number
of shares. He's ready to offer a million
shares. There are three million people
asking for shares. He can't give
everyone what they asked for. You're
going to get one/ird of what you
requested. You're going to get 333
shares in that company. Next company,
let's say you have a million shares and
2 million subscriptions. You're going to
get 500 shares. Are there some companies
where you get all thousand shares that
you asked for? Yes, Sophia.
In fact, they're going to drop. So on
those companies where you get a,000
shares, you say, "I wish I hadn't got
those thousand shares, you see what's
going to happen to your portfolio,
right? At the end of the game in you're
going to have a portfolio that's
overweighted in overpriced IPOs. You're
going to get a thousand shares and
underweighted in the IPOs you really
wanted." You're not the first people to
think about, hey, I can make money.
There were funds, mutual funds that were
started after these studies came out
saying, "This is an easy way to make
money. we'll just buy every IPO and at
the end of the year when they looked at
the returns they discovered they were
making what everybody else was
making. So the first thing of why don't
people exploit the underpricing the
answer is easy. It's not easy to
exploit. I have a second
question. Let's say bankers are open
about the fact and they are open that
they're going to underpric the offering
by 15 or 20%. Who
loses from that underpricing?
Whose money is it that they're giving
away? The founder and VC money.
Basically, they're leaving money in the
table, right? So, let's say you're the
founder of a company or the VC invest in
the company and I'm underpricing your
offering. I am taking your money and
transferring it to the people who get
those shares. Why are you okay with
that,
Sophia? You're getting liquidity, but
you might not care about liquidity if
you're selling all your shares, right?
The the initial offering was you are
selling all of the shares you have as a
founder. Of course, you're going to be
pissed
off. But this is the same thing. If I'm
selling all my shares, I don't care
about momentum. But if a founder is
holding Oh, no. That's too messy. The
tax guy will get you. You're thinking
too messy.
Most offerings, you know what percentage
of shares get offered on the open on the
offering day? Less than
10%. You see how the founders's mind
works, right? If you're a founder of VC,
you're okay leaving money on the table
on that first five or 10% because you
hope to sell your shares 6 months or a
year or a year from now because you're
actually locked in. You can't sell right
now. What you want is that great story
the next day in the Wall Street Journal
that says stock price jumps 50% on IPO.
Who reads that story?
Sheep. And what do sheep do? They do
what other sheep do? You're hoping that
that story will draw other people into
the
stock and that'll push up the price even
more. It's it's a dream that you have
that 6 months from now when you try to
sell your shares, you're going to get a
higher price because the momentum. That
wasn't always the case. When Apple went
public, 60% of the shares owned by VCs
and founders were offered in the
offering. The 1980s, much of the
company was made available in the
offering. When Facebook went public,
less than 10% of the shares
did. So why do founders and VCs accept
it? because to them it's a small slice
of a very big pie and they're playing
the long
game. I have a third question,
right? I told you the typical structure
for an IPO. The IPO is when a private
business goes to a banker. Somebody help
me with all of the things that the
banker does in return for that six or
eight because they get a pretty hefty
slice of it. What are some of the things
going? They underwrite. They guarantee a
price, but that's like a realtor
guaranteeing you a price, but not
telling you what the price is, right?
They guarantee a price, but it's set too
low. They market it, right? Basically,
one thing they do is they market your
company and company people have not
heard of your company. So, the road
show, what else? So, they do marketing,
they do pricing badly, but they do
pricing. What else do they
contribute? You're a young unknown
company. You pick Goldman Sachs as your
banker. Why are you doing it?
Or investors say if Goldman Sachs is
taking the company public there must be
something there. It's a complete lie but
you believe that right? They bring
credibility. And finally in the post
offering they offer you support price
support which is not huge amounts. They
don't have the cash but they'll keep
your price from dropping but coming in
and buying shares. Morgan Stanley did
this with Facebook in the first two
weeks after because the offering did not
go
well. Those are all big deals 50 years
ago, 40 years ago. Why? Because a
company going public was relatively
unknown. And if Goldman Sachs or Morgan
Stanley did not take them public, people
say, "I'm not buying shares in that
company. I don't know what's in the
company." This is like the Good
Housekeeping seal, right? A bank.
But each of those things that bankers do
has become less valuable over time.
Let's take the marketing, the road show,
right? One celebrity endorsement for
your stock can cover what 50 road shows.
You get LeBron James to say, "Buy the
shares in the company. People are lining
up." The marketing part has become much
more diluted. The you don't need the
investment banker. You just need social
media. You need other ways to get it out
there.
We talked about companies that are
unknown and the banker is the reason
people learn that when Facebook was
taken public, Morgan Stanley was its
investment banker. I'll wager that on
the day Facebook went public, more
people had heard the name Facebook than
the name Morgan
Stanley. For some companies, you don't
need an investment bank say, "Let's tell
the world who you
are." If you're a high-profile company,
Uber going public, by the time it went
public, we all had Uber on our phones.
since we knew exactly what it did.
Sophia about Palunteer, let's pick any
high-profile company.
Pelaton, I would argue that in most of
these companies, you don't need the
investment bank. You have the prospector
is you know what the company does. The
advantage you get from an investment
banker offering that seal is less
valuable now than it used to be because
we have more access to the information.
We have more news, more data. Third, we
talked about the credibility effect,
right? Which is you lived in the
reflected glory of a Goldman Sachs.
Those days are done. Now, I'm not sure
if attaching Goldman Sachs to myself
lowers my credibility or raises it.
Right? This is the post208 world we live
in where investment bankers are not up
there in the esteem standings. They're
down here. What I'm trying to say in a
long-winded way is all of those things
that bankers bring to the game is
getting less valuable. So something's
got to change in the system, right? So
what's the first thing that can change?
That 6 or 8% fee should become 4 3 2 1%.
Right? You're not providing as much.
Second, do you actually need to set an
off? This seems very artificial, right?
Set an offering price and then open
trade. Could you skip that offering
price and just go directly to the
market? You could do it. In fact, Google
was one of the first high-profile
companies to do it. They said, "We don't
need a banker. People know who we are.
Why the heck would we need Goldman Sachs
to tell the world what we're worth?
We're going to open to demand and
supply, setting the price." Nothing's
left on the table then if you're a VC or
a founder. It's called a direct
listing. The question is why don't more
companies do it? Especially high-profile
companies. Very small company people
don't know about. You might still need
the banker. Why don't more companies do
direct listings? Bill Gurley who is a
partner at Benchmark Capital. We talked
about him in the context of Uber has
been a strong proponent that more
private companies should use direct
listings. You know what the problem with
direct listings is? Anybody?
It's not that you can game the system
because bankers game the system. So what
difference does it make who games the
system,
right? There's a problem with direct
listings that the SEC has put a
restriction on direct
listings. If you do a direct listing and
you raise cash, remember we talked about
the three uses you can have for cash.
You can use it to pay, you know, let
equity investors cash out. You can use
it to keep in the company or you can use
it to pay down debt. If you do a direct
listing, only the first option can be
used. In other words, it's got to leave
the company. So, if you're a small, if
you're a growing company, you're doing
an offering because you want to have the
capital to cover your reinvestment
needs. A direct listing doesn't work
because of those restrictions. Don't ask
me why they have the restrictions. I
think they should be removed, but
they're still there. So, direct listings
have never taken off.
Yes. No. No. Remember, you can't be held
liable for things that are not fraud,
right? I mean, the Delaware courts
essentially have ruled that you can't be
held liable for not meeting estimates.
You can't be unless they show that you
cook the estimates and you committed
fraud. So, I don't think that's going to
give you any legal cover. Even having a
bank won't protect you because the
projections are still coming from the
company. So you're not you're not any
more any less
exposed. They can sue. I mean this is
the this is the United States of
America. You can sue anybody on any
given day for anything. Doesn't mean you
will win. To win on a business thing,
you have to show not just negligence,
not just that you didn't do your job,
but that you committed outright fraud.
That's tough to do.
So direct listings haven't taken off,
but in 2019 and you had a question about
direct listing. Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. So you cash out as
owners like Spotify is a classic
example. So in 2000, so direct listings
haven't displaced. So people are not
happy with the banker IPOs. Direct
listings haven't taken off. So in 2019 a
third structure opened up. Anybody know
what it was called?
Spaxs. Anybody want to describe to me
how a spack
works? Want to
try? So you're going to create the spec.
So let's go ahead and create the spec.
So what is the spec?
So you list it. So no remember you've
created the listing. So you go
public without any business. You say,
"Why would I do that?" Right? Just for
the same reason you invest in a private
equity fund, right? You're investing. So
you collect the
cash. So you now have a publicly traded
shell company whose only asset is cash.
You're saying why would I do
that? You have a window. It's two years,
three years. And during that window,
what do you try to do as the the people
person running? you
tr in other words instead of having the
private company go public the spa buys
the private business and the minute it
acquires the private business that
private business now inhabits the shell
company so you're a software company the
minute I do the spec the software
company now trades as the original spa
company did you filled in the
space the question is what are the costs
and what are the benefits
You're investing your money in a spa.
The spa founder creator takes your money
and here's the first problem. They take
20% of your money right off the
top. Where did the 20 come from? They
probably stole it from the hedge fund
guys who do the two and 20. Let me take
20% off. So if there's they raise a
100red million 20 million goes into
Chamat Palapatia's pocket right there.
Okay, you got 80 million now left still
in cash. You're saying why would I leave
Chamat with my 80 million? I never
would. But no, clearly people are. What
are you hoping he will
do? What is his
reputation? And why why do we think he
has the capacity to do
that? He's a smart guy. He has a
podcast. He used to work at Facebook was
it number I mean basically he has a tech
background. And what do you think all of
this will do? that he will find this
great little tech company and buy it at
the right
price. That's a lot of ifs along the
way. And if none of this turns out, one
of the protections you have in his back
is you can take your money back at any
time. So basically, it looks like an
easy play until you factor in the 20%
loss and the fact that Chamat might not
work in your best interest. He might not
even know how to value companies.
He might be picking companies,
overpaying for them. A spec is almost
designed to blow up because of that 20%
slice. But it doesn't have to be 20%,
right? Bill Aman created a speck with a
6%
slice. And now we're talking about an
interesting
structure because you might say Bill
Aman is a great private equity investor.
He knows what he's doing. Let me ask you
a question. Warren Buffett had created a
spa 20 years ago or 30 years ago. Do you
think people would have invested in the
spa? Absolutely. You can see a spa
structure might work for a very special
investor who doesn't take 20% but takes
three or four or
5%. So we're I think in this strange
place where the old way of doing things
is no longer working. We're trying new
ways. The spaxs direct listings they're
not jelling either. But one thing I can
guarantee going forward, I think the way
companies go public is going to
bifrocate. If you're a company like
Google or Facebook or Twitter with a
high profile, I think you're going to go
the direct listing route. Cut out the
middleman because he's not doing much
for you. If you're a small company and
people don't know much about you, you
might still go with the banking
structure, but your fees are going to be
structured to how much work the banker
puts. It's almost like, you know how,
you know, when you buy a house, the way
in which realtors get compensated in the
United States makes absolutely no
sense. How much when you buy or sell a
house, what what
happens and the commission is actually
3% on each side. And it used to be 3%
each side, whether you had a $100,000
house or a $10 million house or a
billion dollar house. I don't think
anybody has a billion dollar house. It
was an absurd system.
That system is obviously under tension,
but look at how much they're holding on,
right? You got a Supreme Court ruling
now against the way realtor set fees.
You got Zillow and Red Fin trying to
take away the business, but inertia is a
nasty beast. It just hangs in there.
This is not going to change overnight,
but the way we do IPOs is shifting. But
now I want to talk about something else
that has shifted in the IPO process. In
this graph, I've actually, you know,
listed out the typical characteristics
of a company going public each year
starting in 1980 going all the way
through 2020. Let's go back to 1980.
Typical company going public, Apple went
public in 1980, for instance, had
revenues of 50
million. And 90% of companies going
public in 1980 were making money
already. Positive net income.
The typical company going public in 1980
was a small company with a working
business model. Let's fast forward 40
years. Typical company going public has
revenues of almost 100. So much more in
revenues. Much larger company. But
here's the other statistic. Less than
20% of companies were making
money. The typical company going public
in 2020 was a much bigger company
without a working business model. God
help us. Right? This is the fact the the
effect of VCs scaling up companies
without building business
models. The type of company going public
has become
larger. So how can companies get so much
larger now? What has happened in the
rest of the market that's allowing
companies to stay private and become so
big? Do VCs have a lot more
money? Maybe a little bit, but not by
that much. So, what's happening in that
space that's allowing a private company
to continue to raise capital that they
couldn't do 40 years
ago, but still they have limited
capital, right? So, where's the extra
money coming from?
Yes, still VCs. That's just a subset of
VCs. No, that'll be a terrible way to
raise capital. You'd go bankrupt, right?
There's VC debt, but that's not a big
chunk. Yes.
You know, take a look at what how Uber
raised capital in 2014, 2015, 2016. It
wasn't VCs anymore. 2016, it was a Saudi
investment, sovereign funds, Fidelity,
and Tro equity investors were investing
in private companies. We've created this
gray space where private companies can
now raise capital from investors who
weren't in that space anymore. What does
it mean? Effectively, you can get much
bigger as a private company. Think about
it. You're now getting the best of both
worlds, right? You're able to scale up,
but you don't have any of the disclosure
requirements and the corporate
governance requirements of being a
public company. You get to be a 10
billion, 20 billion, $50 billion company
before you go public.
And as this has happened, the other
statistic is fewer and fewer shares are
being offered on that first day of
trading. So instead of 50 60% of the
shares, 10% of the shares are being
offered, which means you're going to get
less care about the pricing because it
becomes almost like lost leaders in a
department store. You know what lost
leaders are? a table full of cheap
things and they suck you deeper and
deeper into the store and leave you by
the Ralph Lauren section where you
overspend. Basically, they're drawing
you in with that
underpricing. So, one final thing before
we put this to rest.
We've talked so far about IPOs and
public companies, right? Let's say you
start a private business. You're a
founder. Initially, where does your
capital come from? It comes from you.
Completely undiversified. That total
beta we talked about kicks in. Let's say
you succeed in terms of growing your
firm. Things are going well. What's your
next step? You don't go public. You go
to venture capitalist. Venture
capitalists are a little more
diversified than you are. Why? Why?
Because they own 15 or 20 companies in a
sector. Angel financing. Angel financing
tend to be focused little more. So what
does that mean? Your correlation with
the market goes up. Your total beta
comes
down. You keep growing. You now approach
private equity investors and maybe
bigger venture capitalist even more
diversified. Their correlation with the
market is now 7.8. The total beta comes
down even more. And then you finally go
public. At which point what do you do?
You have a market beta. You see how this
is going to play out in a discounted
cash flow valuation, right? When I do a
discounted cash flow valuation, my total
beta will shift for my company,
especially if I think this company has
great
potential early on. I'm going to use a
total beta. Why? You're the founder.
You're the you're the only person
invested in the company and not
diversified. As you approach venture
capitalists, I'm going to use a much
lower beta because the correlation, it's
the same company, same business, but
because the investors are more
diversified, my total beta decreases.
And by the time I go public, my total
beta is equal to my market
beta. My cost of equity goes from 24%
early on when I'm the only investor to
14% when venture capitalists enter in
down to 9% when it becomes a public
company.
So in my discounted cash flow valuation
there's my cost of equity line. When my
discount rate changes remember it's
going to have consequential effect on my
value. And in this case the correct
value for the company is $1.5 billion.
If I do things
right. I would challenge you to actually
find private company valuations where
people actually do this. You know what
you'll tend to find? They'll either use
the 24% all the way through. In which
case, what are you doing? You're
penalizing the company because you're
attaching a total beta for an
undiversified investor all through its
life, including the terminal value. The
value that you get is 1.2 million, much
lower than it should be. Alternatively,
there are other people who are in denial
who act like it's not a private
business. They go directly to the 9%
cost of equity and use it all the way
through. In which case, you're going to
overvalue the company. It's a Goldilocks
scenario. You want to bring in the fact
that investors are not diversified right
now, but you also want to factor in that
that will shift over time as a company
gets bigger and is able to attract more
capital when you think about valing
private companies. That's something you
have to factor in. But there are
implications if you take that to the
next step. If you're valing a private
business, it should have more value if
you're in a sector where companies are
more likely to go public technology
companies. When I value private
technology companies, the penalty of
that total bait dissipates very quickly
because most technology companies tend
to go public. You own a hardware store.
I'm not scaling you up and taking you
public because how the heck am I going
to do that? You're not the Home
Depot. So, in some businesses, this
effect is going to be much greater than
others. You're a private business in a
market where it's difficult to go
public. I will value less than if you're
in a market where it's easy to go
public. One of the advantages of being
in the US market is you have that exit
strategy of being able to go public. You
know how few tech companies in Europe
actually go public? I would value a tech
company in Europe a lot less than a
otherwise similar tech company in the
US. So you know what tech companies in
Europe do? They list in Silicon Valley,
right? it's
almost guaranteed to happen if that's
the case. So when you look at private
companies, that is the transition you're
trying to bring in. And the easier you
see the transition to being a public
company, the less you will penalize a
private business for being
private. So that when you think about
total beta, keep those things in mind.
So let's summarize. You're valuing a
private business. Motive matters.
You you need to tell me why you want the
value before I can even get started.
Whether it's for taxes, a divorce court,
or for a transaction, you need to tell
me who you plan to sell it to. You also
need to figure out what kind of buyer is
interested in your company. Is the buyer
diversified? Because that's going to
affect. Do you see what this means,
right? In a private company valuation,
you need to have a much longer
conversation with the person that you're
valuing the company for. And that's a
good thing because chat GPT might not be
able to do it. There are far more to add
to the process in a private company
valuation. So as you as you look at
private companies, don't create new
rules. It's the same process. And the
question is how do you adapt the process
to deal with the fact that you can
invest your money elsewhere. Yeah.
No, I think I would value it as a part
because the marginal investors who trade
the stock and drive the price are still
the the diversified and the only thing
is I tell the family your job is to keep
investors happy not the family happy
right and that's a big deal right
because family say what's good for us
and I said look you've gone public this
is not about you you want to maximize
your wealth you got to keep the
institution traditional investors who
are the marginal investors in your
company happy really tough to do in
family businesses because they think oh
it's our wealth we're I understand but
you still have to run the business for
those investors because they're the ones
who set prices Mark Zuckerberg has to
worry about what Fidelity thinks about
matter far more than what he thinks
about matter and that's mindset that's
actually tough to develop if you're an
entrepreneur because you got to think
about those outside investors
So, I'm going to close up packet two and
even if you didn't bring packet three, I
will at least get started
because and I want to start with a very
simple review of basic option pricing. I
know you guys have all mastered option
pricing. You know the black Scholes
model inside out, but I'll act like you
don't. And let's start with the very
basics. This next section of the class,
we're going to talk about what are
called real options. And I'll be quite
honest, real options have become a
buzzword. Consultants use it, bankers
use it. They use it to justify a
premium. Remember the the weapons of
mass distraction? It's become a weapon
of mass distraction. So, I'm a skeptic.
When people say real options, I have
some questions to ask. And I want to
give you those questions because people
are going to throw real options at you.
And I want you to be able to separate
the wannabes from the options that have
truly have value. So let's set the let's
set the table. You remember in corporate
finance you computed the net present
value of a
project. You took the cash flows, you
discounted them back at a the right cost
of capital. You compare the initial in
and what's the rule with
NPV for a project? If it's positive, you
take the project. If it's negative, you
reject the project. Right? That's basic
capital budgeting. All of corporate
finance is built around
that. When you do a net present value
for a project, you're asking the
question, is this a good project today?
And it answers that question, right?
Positive net present value, good
project, negative net present value, bad
project. But here's what you might be
missing. Let's say you have the rights
to this project for the next 10 years.
You computed the net present value
today. you came up with a negative net
present value. Are the rights to this
project therefore worth nothing as well?
Why might the rights have value? You
know, if the net present value is
negative, why would having the rights to
this project for the next 10 year have
value? That's a very convoluted way.
It's very defensive, right? There's
actually a more aggressive way you can
think about it. The project has negative
net present value today. Let's say it's
a nonviable technology in AI. Could the
technology become viable 2 years, 3
years, 4 years from now? Markets can
change, costs can change. There's an
option here, an option. If you wait,
this project that's bad project could
become a good project. We're going to
use this to talk about why patents can
have value even if they're not viable.
Technologies can have value even if
they're not viable. oil reserves can
have value even though the oil price is
too low
today. Second stop, it doesn't reflect
the fact that as the person running the
project, you can adjust how much you
produce based on something you see. I
don't want to be mysterious, but let's
say you're valuing an oil reserve. There
are 150 barrels of oil under the ground.
15 years to get it out. So, you say 10
million barrels each years. Basic math,
right? You take the cash flows. What are
we missing when we do that? Are you
locked into producing exactly 10 million
barrels a
year? In fact, why what why might you
produce more in some years and less in
others? Because you check the price of
oil, right? If the oil price is $100,
you might produce 15 million barrels.
The oil price drops to 40, you might
drop to 5 million barrels of oil. If you
can adjust the production schedule, you
can increase the value. We're missing
that with a traditional discounted care.
That's an optionality.
Third stop. Let's suppose you're
investing in a big market. Give the big
market name. AI, China,
India. And you do your initial analysis,
you come up with a negative net present
value. So what does it tell you? Don't
go into that market. Right? But let me
play devil's advocate. Let's suppose by
taking this investment which has a
negative net present value, so we're not
debating it. There's a chance if this
investment works well, you have the
right to expand into the rest of the
market. Remember, it's a much bigger
market. Right now, that right is worth
nothing. The OB, but there's an option
here. It's an option to expand. Option
to delay, option to adjust, option to
expand. And here's a final option. Let's
say you're an infrastructure company.
What's a typical time horizon for an
infrastructure investment? 30 years, 35
years, 40 years, right? And you make a
big upfront
investment and you have cash flows that
you hope will cover that initial
investment. You go in expecting a
positive net present value. Is it
possible that the cash flows could
disappoint
you? And if you're locked in for the
next 35 years, you're now collecting
probably negative cash flows for the
next 30
years unless you can walk away from that
investment. It's called the option to
abandon where you say, "Look, no, we
built this theme park expecting positive
cash flows and now negative cash flows.
We're going to shut the theme park down,
turn it into parking lots, and get what
we can. These are all options that are
all being ignored when you do a
traditional static analysis, which is
what a net present value
is. So to understand where the value of
real options come from, I'm going to go
back to a very simplistic example.
So decision tree 50% chance of making a
100 million 50% chance of losing 120
million. Where do you take this
investment? What's the expected
value? Minus 10. Right? I'm going to do
some magic here. So does everybody get
the minus 10? 50% of 100, 50% of one.
I'm going to take that same investment
and break it up into two subp parts. So,
first you take an initial investment
where there's a 75% chance of making
plus 20 and a 25% chance of losing 20.
If you make the plus 20, you follow up
with a second investment where there's a
2/3 chance of making 80 and a one-/ird
chance of losing
100. You add up the losses 100 minus 100
minus 20 that's - 120 + 20 + 80 I'm
sorry as the plus 100 in terms of the
total upside and downside it looks
exactly the same but here's the magic if
you take the expected value of the
second
investment it's
positive so what is it about the second
investment that turning a bad investment
into a good investment
you In other words, there's learning
from the first. It's like a test market,
right? If you get a good outcome in the
test market, you invest the extra
amount. You learn and you change the way
you behave. So, if you get a bad
outcome, you don't invest. The building
blocks for real options are learning and
adaptive behavior. Remember the oil
company? Where did the value of the
option come from? They observed the oil
price and then they changed how much
they produce. If they produce the same
number of barrels of oil, no matter what
the price was, there's no optionality.
learning and adaptive
behavior. You're going to see a lot of
real options wherever you go to work.
People who throw the word around. So,
I'm going to give you the three
questions you need to ask and answer
before you start to attach premiums for
real options. First, you got to ask when
should we even be talking about options?
And I'm going to argue that a lot of the
time people throw the option word and
they look and say there's no option
here. So, we're going to talk about what
is it that makes an option an option.
Second stop, we're going to ask when
does adoption have significant economic
value? When should I spend the time and
the resources trying to put a number on
it? And I'm going to give you a magic
word to ask when you know to look for
when you look at options. And third,
when can I use an option pricing model
to value the option? So let's at least
start with the first part of it. When is
there an option? What you know when you
think about options they're classified
usually under derivative securities
right what does that
mean derivative securities
yes in other words they're leeches right
they can't live on their own they need
an underlying asset the first thing you
look for in an option is what is the
underlying asset second feature of an
option is the cash flows are contingent
on something happening with the
traditional call option the stock price
goes above the strike price. So you got
an underlying asset, you got a
contingent cash flow and usually options
have a limited life, 2 years, four
years, 5 years. So I'll end today with
payoff diagrams I'm sure you've seen in
your foundations class, your corporate
finance class, which kind of separate
options from every other physical
asset. This what an option playoff
diagram for a call option looks like.
What is what there's the contingency,
right? The stock price exceed the strike
price. stock price exceeds the strike
price, you make the difference. If not,
you lose, but you lose only what you
paid for the option. Your losses are
limited. If you have a put option, the
reverse is true. The stock price drops
below the strike price, you make money.
But the key word is what you lose is
always limited to what you have paid up
front. When we start next class, we're
going to use that feature of option to
talk about what drives the value of an
option because it's going to show up in
your option pricing models in terms of
how we think about risk with options
very differently than how we think about
risk with almost every other asset. So,
I will see you on Wednesday and I will
let you know when the quizzes are done
so you can come pick them up. And uh
tomorrow I'm going to send you an email
about the project listing with a to-do
list so you know what needs to be mopped
up. And uh you know I'll also follow up
with the with a email about the final
exam and all the all the specifics All
right.